it's friday and that means it's time for
friday follies and for that we turn to
fox news analyst
raymond arroyo raymond um there was
a very big birthday this week and it
wasn't our friend chris edwards no
it wasn't barack obama's who was it no
neither of them it was the princess of
montecito
meghan markle marked her 40th birthday
by jumping on a totally impromptu
zoom call or like this show all on the
fly you just make it up as it happens
with her pal comedian melissa mccarthy
now note the oprah chic
backdrop the hair and makeup this is
like the buddy birthday movie you never
asked for
it's my 40th birthday and i've got an
idea this will probably
seem better for you okay
what about an afternoon tea with your
chickens is it okay
if i still do it in the hat
i wouldn't expect anything less thanks
friend bye friend
cheers she's a great actress most
galling about this laura is the fake
royal routine
never has anyone publicly decried an
institution like the royal family
while trying to assume its trappings for
profit and attention like meghan markle
has
she's the evaporane of santa barbara and
her 40 times 40 initiative you'll love
this
it asks 40 of her celebrity friends
because it's her 40th birthday
to give 40 minutes to mentor women so
they can go back to work
all this while she sits at home in
montecito while the nanny cares for art
oh ouch must be nice now raven wasn't
she an
actress at one time is that right yeah
yeah suits she was on that show suits
but this is just another
excuse for brand building and you know
these women in the inner city i know
people
nuns and priests and people who work in
social service they're
with the people who need help they don't
need 40 minutes with a celebrity
they need time not a ted talk okay they
need real mentors
so this stuff about we're helping women
get back to work i mean
you got to shake your head particularly
when it's people like adele
justin trudeau and ibram kendy how much
time are they going to give
a woman in downtown new orleans looking
for work
i know what abram candy will recommend
okay if you want a good job and then to
keep it
make sure you keep re-emphasizing how
racist the work environment is
okay that's ibrahim kennedy's
recommendation what else do we have
laura the most embarrassing part of this
video was at the conclusion
look out the window here no see i don't
really think that
tea with the chickens
this is harry that is harry who
apparently has
transitioned from royal highness to roy
showing off his juggling skills out the
window i guess if the netflix steel goes
south he can always
land a job at the england pavilion at
busch gardens you know we'll just be
juggling in the corner
it's they're so funny are they bringing
comedy to netflix
after considering their one podcast that
they got 40 million dollars for
this might be a step up at least you get
a little entertainment laura how much
time are you going to
promise megan uh to mentor people you
could start with mentoring
i'm waiting for that um invitation
raymond and i'm
okay yeah i have i have my dogs out the
window they're gonna be knocking on the
door
they'll be juggling soon the skies are
getting a lot less friendly laura
a frontier airlines passenger maxwell
berry had a bit too much to drink and he
is accused of groping
and hitting flight attendants while in
air they reacted
this way
[Music]
oh
i love the tape i love they break out
the tape well what else are you gonna do
well it seems a little excessive with
the tape but i guess if they
keep running their mouth uh while the
whole flight is going on maybe what else
are you going to do is stick a sock in
it well i guess
well frontier airlines they suspended
this crew initially laura these are the
heroes of the airway
these poor people put up with so much
crap
you know where's an air marshal when you
need one but here's the thing i looked
this up today
the fda has had 3715 complaints
of unruly passengers like this guy and
they're now
charging people a violation fee of 35
000
so next time you want to tip back a few
too many in first class
don't raymond was it the fda or is it
the faa
was the fbi now regulating the airlines
i think it's efa it's friday all the all
right you always have to be there to
stab it to me
i have a solution here though ingram i
have a solution they need more emotional
support animals i think
in the in the airways maybe we could
start with a python or a hungry lion for
people like
this guy there is a term uh that has
come into vogue now laura
and i want to get your reaction to this
when describing hispanics
people use this term more than 60
of latin next americans flat and latinx
residents it's awful hard as well
to get latinx vaccines as well
now when certain parties use this term
it sounded a little bit different
after its main graduation it is holding
ceremonies for native asian latinx
and black students at the end of april
oh whether latinx or latinx most
hispanic americans agree with me laura
no nos gusto uh i know a new gallup poll
finds that 38
of hispanics prefer the term hispanic
or latino see i thought latinx was kind
of a i liked latinx so it kind of was
it was exotic i i mean i don't know what
i was thinking sphinx latinx
minks no i don't know i don't like the
latitude we don't have
italian x or caucasian ex why do we have
latinx it's it's
uh liberals liberals always screw it up
all right quickly what's the last thing
well before we go uh we have a free
style and biden alert watch
joe where are you come here
[Music]
places that have offered the hundreds
out of the hundred thousand
a hundred dollars that'd be really good
i'd go back and get vaccinated three
times
but all kidding aside offered the
hundred dollars to get vaccination
have seen an uptick of 25 percent of
daily vaccination rates
a pandemic the ah
the aaa ninh and pi community i
stumble over myself here
how is this any different from his other
appearances laura he always stumbles
over himself
and i'm not kidding here in all
seriousness i'm not kidding it's no joke
i mean someone has to put a rest to that
aside by joe biden
number one it's never funny and it's
tedious
okay all kidding aside raymond all right
have a great weekend raymond thank you
too bye-bye hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else